[Musique]
une abeille butine des grains de pollen
quand la cepalc
en transportant de pollen de fleur en
fleur l'abeille joue un rôle écologique
crucial elles pollinisent les plantes
assurant du coup leur reproduction
jusqu'à présent on croyait que les
pollinisateurs
j'ai fait uniquement sur la terre ferme
comme l'abeille or on vient de découvrir
ailleurs dans un lieu inattendu des
herbiers marins sont parmi les
écosystèmes les plus productifs du monde
ils sont l'habitat d'une myriade
d'animaux qui s'y réfugient et s'y
alimentent la nuit venue cette vie
foisonnante s'endort et laisse la place
à une vie microscopique les fleurs de
tara fiat est dit nome l'erba tortue qui
s'ouvre pétales par pétales
des grains de pollen s'agrippe le nom
des étamines mes organes reproducteurs
mâles
ces grains sont enrobées de musil âge un
mucus collants et paie un véritable
nectar
c'est alors que des petits invertébrés
du fond marin se sortent de leur
cachette et se rapproche des fleurs
que font-ils pour le savoir des
chercheurs de l'université nationale
autonome du mexique ont récolté des
fleurs de talassia et des invertébrés du
fond marin
ils les ont placés dans des aquariums
sous l'oeil attentif de la caméra
des invertébrés comme ces petits
crustacés sévère marin et ses larves
recherche les fleurs ils viennent se
nourrir du mucilage entourant les grains
de pollen
celui ci adhère à leurs pattes leur tête
leur corps comme les abeilles les
invertébrés marins transporte le pollen
de fleur en fleur
dans leur parcours les grains de pollen
se dépose sur les pistes il les organes
reproducteurs femelle des fleurs la
fécondation réussite
la vie se poursuit le transport du
pollen chez les plantes marines se fait
par les courants
comment expliquer que talassia utilise
aussi un mode de pollinisation terrestre
la réponse se trouve dans l'évolution
les ancêtres des herbiers marins sont
des plantes à fleurs des milieux
terrestres et des étangs dépendant de la
pollinisation par les insectes dans la
ciat aurait donc conserver ce mode de
pollinisation
même après sa reconquête des fonds
marins une stratégie qui lui assure un
succès reproducteur en participant à la
pollinisation des herbiers les
invertébrés des fonds marins sont en
quelque sorte les abeilles des mères
[Musique]